ce dimanche 10 juillet les golfeurs ont
troqué leur club contre les crampons et
un ballon au golf des yvelines la 14e
étape de la coupe de france de foot golf
était d'organiser sur les greens de
structures comme son nom l'indiqué ce
sport mélange les deux disciplines
bonjour vraiment avec les règles du golf
mais avec les outils du football c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous avez un ballon de
foot taille 5 un ballon times standard
on va dire et le pied mais par contre
vous je vais vraiment sur les règles du
golf avec donc toutes les difficultés
que présente le parcours de golf les
bunkers les plans d'eau les greens
créée en 2009 aux pays bas ce sport est
pratiqué aujourd'hui dans 45 pays qui
compte près de 3000 licence et une
vingtaine de clubs en france des
compétitions nationales européennes et
mondiales sont organisées chaque année
une compétition par équipe de deux
l'après midi c'est le schéma classique
de la football cup
toutes nos étapes sont sur le même
schéma avec les deux formats de
compétition pour pratiquer cette
discipline tenue correcte exigée les
joueurs doivent s'habiller de façon
élégante avec des chaussettes hautes et
avec des crampons stabilisés et pour
être un bon fou de golfeurs il faut en
plus du style avoir quelques qualités
techniques il faut doser il faut cibler
il faut assurer donc c'est un vrai sport
technique c'est un vrai sport mental
aussi
ça nous arrive aussi de passer à travers
un trou 2 qui nous coûte
un podium par exemple la demande des
qualités de footballeur ça c'est
indéniable il faut quand même être bon
footballeur
celui qui a jamais joué au foot ça va
être compliqué quand même et après
beaucoup de concentration pour marquer
de beaucoup le foot golf peut se
pratiquer sur 32 parcours de golf en
france dans les yvelines château propose
un terrain avec neuf trous un
partenariat est également envisagée avec
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines dans les prochaines années